hi GQ I'm more polter this is my life in
sneakers
I think these shoes go in the legendary
category I don't know what they're worth
they're around two thousand six hundred
dollars are they really
no I'm not selling them for love no
money they're from the 10 collection
designed by Virgil ablo between
off-white and Nike the Classic Air Force
One but deconstructed in the way that
you know is so kind of iconic with
Virgil they are in a case uh safe and
sound I did wear them once or maybe
twice I don't anymore and I won't I
don't think I think the Air Force One is
probably my favorite silhouette for a
Nike shoe everything about its structure
and its layout is kind of perfect and
it's just like the ultimate sneaker
really I love these shoes so much
[Music]